these young people say Jordan Peterson
should not be allowed to speak on their
campus
Peterson's a psychology professor at the
University of Toronto when Canada
proposed a law declaring it illegal not
to call someone by their preferred
pronoun in other words illegal not to
address those who don't want to be
called he or she is say z or Zim
Peterson said he would not obey that law
it's not just students object hundreds
of his colleagues signed a petition
demanding the Peterson be fired they say
his behavior is a danger now when he
tries to speak protestors often surround
him blowing air horns or screaming to
make sure others cannot hear him at this
school he and students who wanted to
hear him moved outside to escape the
noise but the protesters just followed
him and drowned him out again
somebody wants to be called Z or sir why
not I don't care what people want to be
called that's fine but that doesn't mean
I should be compelled by law to call
them that the government has absolutely
no business whatsoever ever governing
the content of your voluntary speech but
if I personally said I'd like you to
call me Z or Zen we could have a
conversation about that just like I
would if you asked me to use a nickname
for example so but there's a big
difference between privately negotiated
modes of address and legislatively
demanded compelled speech protesters
call Peterson all sorts of name they've
called me lots of things Hitler that was
one the fact that it has to do with
transgender people is virtually
irrelevant the issue is compelled speech
Peterson handles the protesters well and
you look pretty calm while they're
screaming at you yeah well you know
better to be calm best to let the
unreasonable opposition speak because
they manifest themselves as unreasonable
and then everyone can see it you can
also see it in this video viewed
millions of times
maybe because Peterson stays calm while
the TV host keeps twisting his work
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these talk no
I didn't say that at all he simply says
that natural differences explain most of
the gender wage gap do you believe in
equal pay well I made the argument there
so I could depends and say you don't no
I'm not saying that at all like many in
the left she insists that difference
proves discrimination if it weren't for
our sexist society we'd be much more
alike that's actually not the case the
science on that is absolutely clear
they've studied tens of thousands of
people in dozens of countries and the
papers have been cited thousands of
times for years many leftist denied
there were any differences aren't women
in general better nurturers No next
question feminist icon Gloria Steinem
even objected to researching differences
it's really the remnant of anti-american
crazy thinking to do this kind of
research but more research has been done
and it shows that on average men and
women excel at different things that
runs contrary to well contrary to the
desires of the research used to
generated the data because no one wanted
that it came as a shock to everyone but
that's how it is and yet when you say
this it infuriates somebody it should
infuriate them because I'm going right
after the heart of the radical leftist
doctrine
[Applause]
the heart of that doctor is that all
groups should have equal outcomes there
should be just as many female CEOs
scientists computer programmers because
men and women are the same
if outcomes differ it must be sexism or
as actress Ashley Judd puts it the
problem is the patriarchy the patriarchy
professors teach exactly that the United
States as a patriarchal society first of
all I think the idea that like men
tyrannically dominated everything is a
pretty damn weak argument the year 2002
the year 2012 the rate of absolute
poverty in the world fell by 50 percent
it's like that's pretty good for a
patriarchal tyranny that was the fastest
economic development in the history of
the world but on campus the message is
inequality oppression students major now
in social justice disciplines like
women's and ethnic studies which which
are corrupt
right to the core I plan to use they and
a damn when I do not know someone's
pronounced they're out to produce
radical leftist activists by their own
admission all you have to do is go to
the websites of these disciplines and
look at how they advertise social
justice is different from justice social
justice generally means justice for
groups of people it assumes every group
and women blacks whites should have the
same income job preference everything
Peterson says this is an idea that comes
from Marxist professors it's a little
discredited now to say I'm a Marxist
yeah you'd think so wouldn't you except
I think it's one in five social
scientists identify as Marxist so yeah
it's a little discredited but it's
nowhere near discredited enough it
should be as discreditable to say that
you're a Marxist as it is to say that
you're a Nazi it is on campus
socialism is cherished so Peterson
although it's murderous
we've got a hundred million corpses
stacked up to demonstrate murderous then
but they say those Stalin it's a bad
individual doesn't mean yeah so is so
was Mao so it was Paul Pott the thing is
is it was tried everywhere and the end
consequence was always the same I've
heard this all many many times that
wasn't real communism you know what that
means
that
means that if I would have been the
benevolent dictator in in the place of
Stalin then I would have brought in the
Utopia
there isn't a more narcissistic and
toxic and inexcusable statement that you
can possibly make we actually value the
individual Peterson offers an
alternative and videos that suddenly are
being viewed by millions the individual
has intrinsic value
Peterson calls for the opposite of
Marxism individual sovereignty the
free-market principles the idea of
individual sovereignty above all else's
distribute itself across the world quite
effectively and everyone is doing better
here than anybody has ever done on the
on the face of the planet throughout
recorded history and the whole West is
like that and to call that all a
tyrannical patriarchy is indicative of a
very deep resentment and a historical
ignorance that's so profound that it's
indistinguishable from willful blindness
Peterson says the best thing people can
do to fight back against that blindness
is to speak the truth even when it's
unpopular Peterson follows his own
advice he says unpopular truths and
people like that almost a million have
bought his book